hey guys it's me Debbie and surprise I'm
officially a mom
well motherhood has been an incredible
journey so far but the one thing I can
definitely do without is those unwanted
baby pounds so I hit up my mommy message
boards and asked all my mommy groups and
apparently the secret is shedding those
unwanted lbs
girl this diet has real promise and all
my girlfriends are doing it because they
lost the weight real quick this guy puts
Jenny Craig to shame so naturally I was
gonna try it hey Deb Congrats welcome to
the mommy club so intermittent fasting
has gained a lot of momentum recently
but it's not necessarily new so let's
break it down a little bit for forever
the go-to weight-loss diet was just
restricting calories on a daily basis
but let's be real that really sucked and
was really hard people to maintain so
intermittent fasting was born so with
intermittent fasting you're restricting
calories on certain days or certain
times the day and then the rest of the
time you're free to eat whatever you
want so in a sense it's a lot more of a
flexible way of dieting sounds like my
kind of diet on top of that and most
importantly I hear the fat just melts
away yeah sure intermittent fasting in
the research has been linked to a
decrease in body weight body fat and
waist circumference whether whether or
not you can keep that weight off is a
completely other thing a 2016 review
found that individuals tended to lose
more weight at the beginning of the diet
compared to the final follow-up point
and yes you may lose some body fat but
you may also lose some really important
lean muscle mass having said that it's
possible with the right diet getting
enough protein and exercise regime that
you may be able to reduce or prevent
this well girl you know how much I love
my protein shakes and you can't keep me
out of the gym
crashbug gym rat hashtag gym leg hashtag
west also doesn't enter in fasting like
cure diabetes or some
from the studies I've read intermittent
fasting doesn't cure diabetes however a
2017 review did find that actually could
help reduce blood sugar levels it may
also be a heart-healthy diet because
research suggests that it may help to
reduce total cholesterol blood pressure
and triglyceride levels so it's settled
I need to be all up in interim fasting
not so fast girl let's talk about some
of the concerns that I have with this
diet I know how much that your social
life means to you and intermittent
fasting may put a huge damper on things
with intermittent fasting you've got a
short and eating window and that might
just not work so well with your weekly
brunches and your post gym smoothie bar
hangouts and Debbie if life is not about
spending time with friends and family
eating something delicious what is it
about oh you're right
but since most of my friends are already
doing intermittent fasting we can like
coordinate some kind of intermittent
fasting schedule that sounds really
complicated well speaking of your post
Jim smoothie hangouts in Turpan fasting
may cause you to have less energy and a
few unpleasant side-effects in the 2016
review a few studies found that people
were undergoing intermittent fasting
experience constipation feeling cold
headaches bad temper lack of
concentration and a decrease in energy
granted there was another small trial
that found that a 12-week period of
doing the intermittent fasting diet did
not appear to influence the ability to
exercise however that study was really
short I had a really small sample size
and let's be real if you're constipated
or feeling cold have lack of energy how
to headache and just are hangry as do
you really want to go to the gym don't
think so oh this group hates being
hangry I tend to turn super reckless and
do way too much online shopping no one
likes being hangry also I am NOT a fan
of these feasting periods because
there's a really high risk of the you're
gonna eat a lot more than you actually
need because you're limited to this
really restricted timeframe this of
course can increase the risk of
disordered eating behaviors because
you're not listening to your body's own
hunger it's
Q's and instead are just eating by the
clock well didn't you say that each way
and fasting was heart-healthy high
cholesterol went to my family so if I
can lose weight and say bye Felisha to
my high cholesterol I'll be one happy
girl so the research community has had
some mixed results when it comes to
measuring cardiovascular success in some
studies intermittent fasting has been
shown to increase the good cholesterol
but also increase the bad cholesterol
while in other research is found to
decrease the bad cholesterol while good
cholesterol stays the same obviously it
is all over the place
and we need a lot more research before
we can make some clear recommendations
here at least infant fasting can help me
say farewell to the baby weight right so
let's talk about weight loss
so sales have shown that intermittent
fasting has a significant impact on
metabolism by relying less on
carbohydrates as a source of fuel and
instead breaking down stored fat
however restricting calories too
severely can have the opposite effect by
slowing down metabolism which can
actually cause you to gain weight over
time it's difficult to confirm this
claim because we don't have any
long-term studies testing the
sustainability of this diet we also know
that the dropout rate is pretty bad I
mean a 2016 review found that it was 31%
that should probably tell you something
Debbie that said there's nothing new
here Debbie 95% of diets fail and often
lead to more weight gain over time girl
you've got my hopes up now I gotta find
another way to say peace out to pray go
Debbie and a hello to diet Debbie now
Debbie I don't want to run your life
but you should definitely not be
worrying about weight loss as your goal
especially in those first few months
postpartum well you should be thinking
about is listening to your body and not
letting anyone but you determine how
much and when you eat this diet is not
foolproof
yes you may lose a bit of weight at
first but can you keep it off and not be
hankering all the time I am not so sure
but if you do really want to try
intermittent fasting I highly suggest
you do it under the care
a registered dietician well guys I hope
you enjoyed this video if you did be
sure to give it the thumbs up leave me a
comment below with your thoughts on
intermittent fasting subscribe to the
channel and I'll see you next time on
Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]